♪ ♪
>> Shannon: OPIOID DEATHS IN
AMERICA HITTING A RECORD HIGH,
JUMPING BY 30%.
MORE THAN 93,000 AMERICANS DIED
FROM DRUGS DURING THE PANDEMIC
LAST YEAR.
EXPERTS SAY THE SPIKE IS FROM
POWERFUL SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS LIKE
STREET FENTANYL, WHICH BORDER
PATROL WARNS IS POURING ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
OFFICIALS SAY THEY'VE SEEN THE
226% SPIKE IN FENTANYL SEES THIS
YEAR SINCE 2018.
GREG, THE FIRST TIME I READ THAT
NUMBER HAD TO GO BACK.
226%.
IF WE SAY THAT THIS IS A
NATIONWIDE HEALTH CRISIS, THIS
OPIOID CRISIS, WHAT ABOUT THE
BORDER?
>> Greg: IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRAZY.
BUT FIRST OFF, SAYING THE CAUSE
OF DEATH IS OPIOIDS IS LIKE
SAYING THE CAUSE OF DROWNING IS
WATER.
ALL RIGHT?
TECHNICALLY CORRECT, BUT
ACTUALLY WRONG.
IT COMPLETELY ELIMINATES HOW THE
WATER WAS INTRODUCED TO THE
VICTIM.
AS OPIOID PRESCRIPTIONS GO DOWN
AND CLAMPED DOWN, OPIOID
OVERDOSES SPIKE.
BUT THEY ARE BADLY REPORTED AS
OPIOID OVERDOSES WHEN THEY ARE
ACTUALLY CAUSED BY STREET
FENTANYL, WHICH COMES THROUGH
CHINA, THROUGH OUR BORDER, AND
IT'S MIXED WITH REGARD TO
DOSAGE.
THE CAUSE OF DEATH IS ACCIDENTAL
BECAUSE OF THE UNKNOWN DOSAGE.
IF THEY COULD GET A
PRESCRIPTION, WHETHER THEY ARE
DOING IT RECREATIONALLY OR IT'S
FOR CANCER OR IT'S FOR PAIN,
IT'S NONE OF YOUR BUSINESS.
IT SHOULD BE ALLOWED, BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW YOU ARE DRIVING PEOPLE
TO THE STREETS WHERE THEY ARE
GOING TO DIE.
WHEN THE PRESS REPORTS THIS,
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN?
IT'S LIKE WHAT HAPPENS WITH GUN
CONTROL.
YOU'RE GOING TO TARGET THE
LAWFUL AND ILLEGAL DRUG USERS.
WHEN YOU CRACKDOWN ON OPIOIDS,
IT'S LIKE SAYING, OKAY, THERE'S
INCREASED SHOOTINGS IN CHICAGO,
WE NEED MORE GUN CONTROL LAWS TO
TARGET THE LAW-ABIDING.
SO IT'S B.S.
YOU NEED LEGALIZATION OF ALL
OPIOIDS ACROSS THE BOARD, AND
THE POWER OVER TO THE
INDIVIDUAL, AND LET THEM
RELIABLY FIGURE OUT THE DOSAGE.
THERE'LL BE NONE NONE OF THESE
OVERDOSES.
IT IS SO HARD TO FIND AN
OVERDOSE FROM A PRESCRIPTION
OPIOID UNLESS IT WAS SUICIDE.
OTHER THAN THAT, PEOPLE CAN
CONTROL IT.
WHEN YOU GO TO BUY CIGARETTES,
YOU DON'T BUY ONE CIGARETTE THAT
HAS THE POWER OF A CARTON.
YOU'VE GOT A BOX OF PACKEDS WITH
20 DOSES.
YOU CAN MANAGE IT.
WE HAVE TO INTRODUCE THAT LOGIC
TO THESE DRUGS OR YOU'LL SEE
THIS NUMBER KEEP GOING UP,
UNLESS CHINA KILLS A
DISTRIBUTORS, WHICH THEY WON'T.
>> Shannon: THE CRAZY THING IS
THERE WAS A DROP IN SOME OF
THIS.
BECAUSE FOR A WHILE DURING THE
COVID CRISIS LESS OF IT WAS
COMING IN FROM CHINA.
AND SOME OF THE EXPERT SAID THE
MINUTE IT WAS FALLING BACK INTO
THE MARKET, PEOPLE'S RESISTANCE
WAS SO LOW THAT WHEN THEY GOT
SOME IT WAS ALMOST AUTOMATICALLY
A DEATH SENTENCE.
EMILY, FENTANYL TAKES LESS THAN
WE CAN PROBABLY SEE AT THIS
TABLE TO KILL US.
>> Emily: IT IS SO TRUE.
YOU ARE RIGHT, IT'S A
MULTIFACTOR ISSUE AND IT TAKES
AN ADMINISTRATION WHO GETS IT TO
COMBAT IT.
RECENTLY THE WHITE HOUSE
NOMINATED OR ESTABLISHED A
PHYSICIAN AND SAID THIS IS A
HISTORICAL MOMENT THAT WE HAVE A
PHYSICIAN IN PLACE NOW TO LEAD
THE WHITE HOUSE OFFICE AGAINST
DRUG CONTROL, ET CETERA.
BUT IS HE GOING TO DEAL WITH
CHINA SCHEMATICALLY TAKE A HARD
STANCE ON CHINA WERE LAST YEAR
THE DEA ASSESSED THAT THEY WERE
THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF FENTANYL
ACROSS OUR BORDER?
WILL HE WORK IN CONCERT WITH THE
DEA AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND A BORDER PATROL, OR WILL
THEY BE DEFUNDED?
IS HE GOING TO NAME THE CARTELS
USING HUMAN SMUGGLING THAT ONLY
HAS A SHIELD FOR THEIR
MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR PROFIT DRUG
INDUSTRY AND ALSO A SECONDARY
INDUSTRY?
IS HE GOING TO DEAL WITH THE
GANGS AND COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
USING THESE DRUGS IS A CRIME
SCENE?
THE LIST GOES ON.
I THINK I AM AFRAID FOR HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS VIEWING THIS
AND WILL DELIVER THIS,
ESSENTIALLY CHECKING A BOX.
"LOOK AT US, NOW WE'RE MAKING
HISTORY," AND FAILING TO SEE THE
FOREST FOR THE TREES TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THESE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS THAT ARE
DYING.
>> Shannon: BENIGN, TO THE
HISTORY POINT OF THIS, COVID WAS
A CRAZY YEAR.
PEOPLE SAID THE LOCKDOWNS KEPT
YOU FROM TREATMENT, AA MEETINGS,
FROM ANYTHING.
PEOPLE FELT SO SCARED AND
ANXIOUS AND ISOLATED.
>> Jesse: WE MADE A DEAL WITH
THE DEVIL.
OUR POLITICIANS, FACTORIES AND
JOBS WERE SENT TO THE CHINESE,
BUT THEY SENT US BACK CASH AND
ALSO DEATH.
THEY HAVE THE SYNTHETICS IN
CHINA, THEY SHIP THEM OVER, IT
ARRIVES IN MEXICO, THE CARTELS
TRUCK THEM UP TO THE LABS, AND
THEY SMUGGLE IT ACROSS THE
BORDER AND THEN THE MOB
DISTRIBUTES IT TO THESE GANGS
AND ALL THE INNER CITIES.
IT'S LIKE A BAD ACID TRIP, BUT
INSTEAD OF HAVING A BAD TRIP,
YOU'RE DEAD.
YOU TELL THAT TO JOE BIDEN, YOU
SAY, JOE, YOUR OPEN BORDERS
POLICY IS KILLING PEOPLE, WHAT
ARE YOU GOING TO DO ABOUT IT,
AND HE CALLS YOU A RACIST.
ALL OF THIS TALK ABOUT THE
BORDER IS CLOSED, YOU CAN SAY
THAT'S DISINFORMATION.
IT'S KILLING PEOPLE.
SO HE REALLY HAS ONE SOLUTION,
AND IT'S THREE THINGS.
YOU TAKE THE CARTELS, YOU
DESIGNATE THEM AS TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS, YOU CLOSE THE
BORDER, AND HE SAW MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF TARIFFS AT THE
CHINESE SO THEY CAN'T SHIP
UNILATERALLY AND TO OUR
LIKE THIS.
I'M SORRY, IT'S A SIMPLE
SOLUTION, BUT OUR POLITICIANS
DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
>> Shannon: JESSICA, WHILE THE
BUYING DEMONSTRATION TAKE THAT
HARD LINE WITH CHINA?
>> Jessica: I THINK IT IS
CERTAINLY ON THE LIST WITH THEM,
AND ANGELA MERKEL AND JOE BIDEN
TALKED ABOUT IT YESTERDAY.
THEY MADE IT CLEAR THAT BOTH OF
THEM SAID THEY HAVE THE SAME
STANCES ABOUT CHINA AND RUSSIA.
I KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS A PRIORITY ISSUE DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, SOMETHING
JOE BIDEN TALKED A LOT ABOUT ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, ESPECIALLY
AS HE EMPHASIZED THE
CONVERSATIONS AND CONNECTIONS
HE'S HAD WITH EVERY DAY PEOPLE.
WE ALL KNOW SOMEBODY WHO HAS
OVERDOSED OR SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS
SOMEBODY.
IT'S UNFORTUNATELY GETTING AS
PREVALENT AS KNOWING SOMEONE WHO
HAS HAD CANCER.
WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTROL WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
THE BORDER.
I THINK IT'S A TWO-PRONGED
PROBLEM.
THERE IS AT ISSUE, AND THEN
THERE'S HOW WE TREAT THESE
PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
AND HAVE GONE TO SCHOOL TO
PRESCRIBE THEM FOR PEOPLE WHO
REALLY NEED IT.
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THE NURSE
PRACTITIONERS AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS CAN
TREAT PEOPLE WITH OPIOID
ADDICTION AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN GET WHAT THEY NEED.
THAT IS PART OF JOE BIDEN'S
PLAN, THAT THEY CAN MAKE MORE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TERMS OF
OPIOID TREATMENTS.
>> Shannon: I'VE SPENT SOME
TIME IN WEST VIRGINIA WHERE
THEY'VE HAD A TERRIBLE TIME WITH
IT.
AND KIDS WHO ARE ORPHANS.
BECAUSE EITHER BUT THEIR PARENTS
HAVE DIED, OR ONE IS IN JAIL AND
ONE IS DEAD.
THERE ARE RIPPLE EFFECTS FOR
GENERATIONS FOR THIS, WE'VE GOT
TO FIGURE IT OUT.
>> Greg: I HAVE T